it's time for the
launching chronoscope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour
brought to you every monday wednesday
and friday
a presentation of the launching whitner
watch company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch
and whitner distinguished companion to
the world honored longine
good evening this is david ross
may i introduce our co-editors for this
edition
of the launching chronoscope mr william
bradford huey editor of the american
mercury
and mr henry haslet contributing editor
of newsweek
and editor of the freeman our
distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable james g mcdonald former
united states ambassador to israel
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
well mr mcdonald it's a very great
pleasure to have you on the chronoscope
program this evening
and it's especially a great pleasure to
me because i remember
our friendly association on the new york
times when we were both editorial
writers there and
had adjoining rooms well i think you
left sometime in about
1938 and a lot of things have happened
since then the whole face of the world
has changed
and you in particular have had i've
added a very rich experience
and you have been our first ambassador
the
this country's first ambassador to
israel and you have been
also one of the foremost americans in
support
of that country and we'd like tonight to
discuss some of the problems of that
country
and some of the progress that it's made
so i'd like to begin by asking you
the question which it seems to me most
americans are interested in are most
troubled about
and that is do you think that uh
israeli israel and the arab states
will be able to work out a real peace
i think there will be no war between
israel and the arab states
the situation now as an armistice is
that what there is an
armistice with each of the four
immediate neighbors
with egypt with jordan with syria and
with the lebanon
but i do not anticipate that these
armistices will actually
be transformed into treaties of peace in
the near future why is that
because the arabs for the most part see
no reason
for making peace their standing path
and they i think mistakenly hope
that israel will fall of its own weight
because of the vast number of jewish
immigrants that have been coming to the
country and because of the economic
burdens
which the new state now bears well they
think that preparedness a constant state
of preparedness on the part of israel
will
force those economic burdens to be
heavier is that part of
well the preparedness burden is across
one thing
but beyond that the arabs feel that
the jews by having brought into their
country
nearly 700 000 refugees
when there were only 650 000 jews there
to begin with
have taken on a burden which will be too
heavy for them
now sir can you explain quickly for our
audience
uh just what the economic problem is in
israel first how large is israel is it
the size of one of our states
well about the size of new hampshire
about the size of new hampshire and what
is the population
about a million and a half and uh that
of course has been a rapidly growing
population it's doubled in four years
and uh what uh what type of industry
there what do the people do
to to earn what what is the national
product
well the product which is best known is
citrus
the israelis claim that they have the
best oranges and the best grapefruit in
the world i understand that
the california and florida do not agree
and and they
export uh citrus that's their largest
export
they export certain other specialties
but
the measure of their economic what you
economists call
imbalance is the fact that their
exports are only about 1 8
of their imports now and since since
they are now importing eight
times the value of their exports
how do they make up the difference sir
well they don't make it up
at prison because these imports
are in large part
loans or gifts
and so far as they are loans they
constitute of course obligations
which israel will sooner or later have
to meet and isn't that one of the
things you're interested in now and uh
in helping to promote the sale of the
bonds of the country yes one of the
methods which israel is
using now to meet this imbalance
is to try to sell in this country a
total of 500 million dollars worth of
israel bonds over a period of three
years
the proceeds to be used to buy american
tools
machines supplies of all sorts to
undergird the economy of the new state
has there been any criticism to the
effect that
israel has been trying to industrialize
too fast
it's the most industrialized country in
that area isn't it
yes there has been that criticism
but you see if you have 650
000 jews in israel as was the case to
start with
you bring in within four years seven
hundred thousand
more well there has to be something for
them to do
agriculture is not sufficient and it's
too slow you can't employ them yet
employment and then they have to begin
to do things for themselves to make
their own shoes make their own clothes
so that not everything has to be bought
from the outside
well do you know offhand what the
percentage of the national income is
from industry now as compared with
agriculture or the percentage of
employment in the two
a rough idea i'm afraid i can't give you
the
figures which would be nearly enough
accurate to justify
presenting them here i'm sure i'm sure
so that our audience would be interested
in
the approximate value of the american
investment
in israel over the four years that it's
been a nation how much
american money has gone into the is
israel experiment well american money
has gone into israel in
various forms first place there have
been substantial
united states government loans to israel
first a loan of 100 million dollars from
the export import bank
subsequently a special agricultural loan
of 35 millions of dollars
and more recently a grant in aid of some
60
billions of dollars thus making a total
of over 200 millions of american
governmental funds loans or grants
in addition to that there have been over
this period of years
substantial philanthropic gifts from
the so-called uja the united jewish
appeal in this country totaling
well over 100 million dollars plus that
there is the proceeds from the bonds
the total sold up to date is about 125
million
perhaps israel has received as much as
70 million dollars from that proceeds
in addition you have of course private
investments which have also
totaled a large sum well of the
contributions and investments all
together about what percentage
has the united states furnished or has
come from the united states both
as compared with the rest of the world
well i've never seen the figure
put down in black and white but it must
be very large it must be 90 or 95
and and we americans then have about an
excess of 500 million dollars you would
estimate
now invested in in israel yes that and
more
now uh could you tell us just something
about these 700 thousand people who've
come
in i mean israel is is still a relief
project
isn't it what type are these sick people
old people
they're all sorts the israelis did not
discriminate as nearly all countries
including our own do
against old age against invalidism
and so on israel took them all
they came from about 60 different
countries and the other day
well i say the other day about three
weeks ago i was in bereshiba
you remember the old biblical sailing
saying from
dan in the north to bereshiba in the
south
a few years ago there were only a couple
thousand arabs
in that town now there are about twenty
thousand jews
i went to the school talked to the
director he said we have 22 languages
in our school that's a measure of the
diversity of
the people who have come the official
language is now hebrew isn't it right
but how many people actually speak it or
able to speak it
all the children speak hebrew except the
children of new immigrants and they
learn it very quickly
they learn it so quickly that was very
discouraging to me
the child who's been in the country for
six months
will chatter hebrew on the street like a
sabra that's a native born
but delta adults
many of them speak their own languages
but
the educated israeli the government
official for the most part
will speak uh five or six or seven or
eight languages
they're not illiterate linguistically as
we are for instance the other day i met
a young
child in jerusalem and i said
what languages do you speak she was ten
she said i speak arabic
and hebrew and french
and german and italian
and i'm learning spanish and i of course
what language did you ask the question
in well i asked you
in english as a final question mr
mcdonald i'm sure that our audience
would like you to tell us something
what is the morale in the country has
there been any disillusionment
are the people still enthusiastic over
their efforts to create a new nation
the people are still enthusiastic and
confident
but as you know it's easier to be in
to be unqualifiedly
enthusiastic in time of war now has come
the hard economic pull
and inevitably there has been and is a
measure of disillusionment
but as a supporter of this uh human
experiment
you yourself are still confident that uh
it it is going to work out
satisfactorily i am and i'm confident
that it will be a
civilizing and modernizing and
democratizing influence in the whole of
the man and you regard it as one of the
hopeful
developments in the world today one of
the few hopeful ones yes well thank you
very much for being with us tonight sir
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching chronoscope was mr william
bradford huey and mr henry haslet
our distinguished guest was the
honorable james g mcdonald former united
states ambassador to
israel